[Music]
brandon is with us brandon's in tampa
florida hey brandon how are you
hey dude how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh so i am contemplating switching jobs
and i wanted to give you a little detail
and see if you can help me to make an
informed decision
okay uh so i've worked for the same
company for
15 years i love my company and i think
what i like best about my job is
i work from home i have really flexible
hours
so one of my kids has special needs if
he's meeting with a therapist
i can take a quick break from work and i
can meet with the therapist too
or if they have a function going on at
school i can meet them at school
and i'm home every night for dinner and
then uh
i can walk back into work if i need to
after they're in bed so it kind of lets
me be
super dad uh while you know my kids
still like me you know until they become
teenagers right
okay so the
uh so why are you leaving why are you
leaving nirvana
so unless i move to another city they
won't let me apply for other jobs and
they're going to lay me off
in the next three months to three years
oh okay so this is the end i kind of
nirvana's in there you got kicked out of
the garden
okay i will it's just kind of when do i
pull off the band-aid
right so i i found another job that
would actually pay me more
and it would have a lot of job security
and it'd be a great job
uh but it's probably two to two and a
half hour commute a day
and it would be a lot of hours and i
wouldn't be home or able to do
any of this stuff with my kids yeah
that's a big problem
you'd have to move is what you have to
do yeah
yeah you would last more than three
months your heart your heart's already
telling you that's a bad idea that's
just your brain because you've got a
little bit of fear a little bit of
pressure
so that's not an option unless you move
and then you said i'm not willing to
move why you're not willing to move
um my kids are in a great school
district love my house love my
neighborhood
i have a rental in the same street my
in-laws live on the same street
you haven't found the new job yet yeah
you got to keep looking there's a good
list of reasons why we say no to that
um so i started looking for that other
job that i have
in 2018 and i was getting ready to start
that job
and then it went on hold during the
pandemic and they're trying to get me to
come back now
my wife and i kind of want to just wait
until we get laid off
just so you know i'm on baby step seven
i have a fully funded emergency fund
and a large chunk of money that's in our
checking account because we're getting
rid of my car
um so financially i'm in
good shape where if i got laid off it
wouldn't be the end of the world
but if and when i went to look for
another job
it's very likely that i'd take a big pay
cut because the technology that
i'm working on is very proprietary so
not a lot of other places need it
so i'd have to kind of start at the
ground what's place two and a half hours
away with a raise
do they have the same technology uh
they do it's kind of a government job so
it's not just that it's two and a half
hours away it's that it's uh
a long commute with traffic i got that
part i'm asking what was the job
is it the same technology
uh it's not but they're willing to take
me because of a security clearance
all right so what is your what would you
say is your uh type of work are you a
programmer
are you in cyber give me a give me a job
title so i can have an idea of what
we're looking at here
being your systems engineer one thing
that's kind of funky is my current
company
because i can't apply for jobs they just
move me wherever they need me
so right now i'm not working on
technology i would apply to a job for
because i've been doing it since
february okay here's the deal
in tampa florida a great job market
good size area the systems engineer what
you have to start doing right now is
start finding
other different types of opportunities
that allow you to take your experience
and your skill set those are two
different things but i think you've got
a wonderful future
you know the idea of waiting to be laid
off that's just not how i'm wired but
because you're in baby step seven
and you've got a you've got a whole
different perspective on things
i'm not gonna say that's not a good idea
you certainly can do it it's not
but i don't like it okay good i don't
like it i think that that
is uh too passive and uh brandon you're
in denial
yeah you're in denial that this nirvana
is going away it's going
away and all you have said all you have
set up are these impossible freaking
scenarios that are fatalistic all around
you where
your life is not going to continue
unless you keep this job that's right
and that's a bunch of bs
this you you have a skill set that is
totally marketable
within 30 minutes of your house and you
need to go look for a new position
and that that what has happened dave
those excuses those are all excuses
those scenarios become excuses for him
because he doesn't want to leave the
nevada because he doesn't want to leave
i'm sorry but nirvana's ending they're
kicking you out of the garden of eden
yeah
you don't get to live there anymore yeah
and so it
they've told you and and the instability
of that is is
is eroding you guys it's it's eating at
you guys
and that's why you went and considered
something two and a half two and a half
hours
no yeah that yeah and by the way we just
freaking moved to orlando
oh my god and you know what you don't
have to trade off being a super dad and
being there for your kids
if your scenario changes that again is a
false
choice it's a false narrative and we do
this we create all these reasons why we
should sit tight
and in this situation he's so marketable
the opportunities for him are
endless as a systems engineer i mean
technology
that's the place to be and because he
can go just about anywhere
yeah you're going to be fine son you're
going to be fine but
you know i'm just calling you on your
stuff here you know
you you need to go look for something
that's not two and a half hours away and
if it's a little bit of a pay cut
so what it's um you know and no i'm not
gonna sit and wait on this to come hit
me in the back of the head we know it's
coming
and so um you know
go land you something and get yourself
get yourself a projected future that
feels good again
you don't have a good feeling about your
projected future nothing in your future
that you laid out sounded fun
nothing did and that's just not accurate
there's a way to put together a life
that you love here again
and so amen appreciate you glad you're
at baby step seven
proud of you for doing that it gives you
some options gives you some comfort
don't wallow in the comfort